welcome to get cooking in cloud where we
share the best recipes to apply in your
cloud kitchen
I am Priyanka Vergara and in this
episode we will talk about creating
websites on Google cloud
[Music]
if your business revenue and customer
satisfaction depends on the availability
and scalability of your website then you
are at the right place in this episode
we will present for reference
architectures that let you scale small
or go large depending on your needs so
let's dive in at a high level there are
four different recipes to build websites
depending on where you are in your cloud
journey your business needs and the
maturity of the development and
infrastructure teams one of these will
fit your needs let's see how static
websites are a good option for sites
like blogs where the page rarely changes
after it has been published or where
there isn't any dynamically generated
content all you need to set up a static
website on Google cloud is Google Cloud
storage bucket connected to your domain
name and that's it
pretty easy right now as your business
starts to mature and customers are
interested in buying things from your
website you might need to generate
dynamic content and maybe enable
payments but if your company is still
small maybe you want to be able to grow
your website without worrying about
scaling it based on the increase in
demand in such a scenario we recommend
that you use Google clouds managed and
surrealist offerings like App Engine or
cloud run so you can focus on delivering
features and let Google worry about
operating and managing the
infrastructure this recipe provides a
wide range of features that make
scalability load balancing
logging monitoring and security much
easier than if you had to build and
manage the website yourself for example
when you use cloud run you can code in
any programming language because your
application is deployed as a container
and Google will seamlessly launch and
scale your application for you so give
it a try now for websites with higher
complexity you probably want more
options and control than a managed
platform offers whether it's configuring
your servers or virtual machines
or if it's a need for specific memory
SSDs and GPUs we recommend this third
recipe compute engine compute engine
provides a robust computing
infrastructure but you must choose and
configure the platform components that
you want to use what Google ensures that
resources are available reliable and
easy to use but it's up to you to
provision and manage them the advantage
here is that you have complete control
of the systems and unlimited flexibility
the easiest way to deploy a complete web
serving stack on compute engine is by
using Google Cloud marketplace with just
a few clicks you can deploy any of the
over hundred fully realized solutions
for a more detailed explanation on how
to set up compute engine to serve
scalable and resilient websites stay
tuned for upcoming episodes finally for
a larger business with more developers
and more complicated problems we
recommend you use this fourth recipe and
containerize your applications you will
notice that it becomes really hard to
manage feature rollouts if the website
is one big monolith which makes it
difficult to keep up with the increase
in demand and pace of business container
izing web application provides four key
advantages first is componentization as
your apps design becomes more complex
containers are a good fit for a
service-oriented architecture including
micro services this support scalability
second is portability a container has
everything it needs to run your app and
its dependencies are bundled together
this facilitates the portability and
fixes the it works on my machine problem
that many developers have the third is
rapid deployments when it's time to
deploy your system is built from a set
of definitions and images so the parts
can be deployed quickly reliably and
automatically compared to what your
machines containers are typically
smaller and deploy much quicker using
contain
to deploy web apps on gke has further
advantages because one container
orchestration is built-in to Google
cloud offers container registry which is
a private storage for container images
and three you can easily use the other
components of Google cloud platform in
your architecture using this container
based recipe makes sense if you have
complicated website with multiple
different moving pieces which are better
off in separate services for easy
management that's all for today on get
cooking in cloud whether you're a small
blogger looking to grow your community
or a huge multi scale ecommerce site
hopefully you've cooked up something
great
join us next time because we will share
the recipe to host a static website on
Google cloud if you would like to see
more such content don't forget to Like
and subscribe to our Channel
[Music]